네, 안녕하세요. 이번 영상은
2026년에 BSN이 어떤 거를
계획하고 있는지 여러분들한테 좀
설명을 드리려고 하는데 굉장히 좀
여러 사업들을 좀 많이 준비를 하고
있어요. 우선 첫 번째로 부동산
중개법인 같은 경우에는 지금
중계사님들이 한 100분 정도 계시고
그리고 지금 빌딩뿐만 아니라 주택도
같이 하고 있거든요. 근데 지금 물론
이제 대부분 다 이제 빌딩 매매라든지
임대 그리고 이제 관리를 주로 하고
있지만 주택 부분도 저희가 좀
늘리려고 준비 중이고요. 그리고
건축사 사무소랑 지금 건설사도 같이
운영 중인데 건축 같은 경우에는 물론
요즘에 워낙 경기가 안 좋고 그리고
이제 건축 건수가 좀 많이 줄긴
했지만 최근에 용적률 완화라든지 뭐
이런 부분도 있고 그리고 이번에
경기가 안 좋으면서 제가 느꼈던게
경기가 좋을 때는 진짜 수많은
업체들이 많이 비딩하고 막 들어오고
그랬었거든요. 근데 경기가 안
좋아지니까 살아남는 사람한테 일거리가
가더라고요. 그래서 이번에 좀
느끼면서 최근에 그런 건들로 수주를
조금 하고 있거든요. 그래서 내년에
좀 더 단단하게 다지고 계속
살아남아서 더 독보적으로 될 수 있게
좀 준비를 하고 있습니다. 그리고
저희가 좀 번 외적으로도 많이
생각하는게 그 패밀리 오피스 지점을
좀 만들고 싶었어요. 그래서 뭐 지금
고객분들도 그렇고 대부분 다
자산가분들이 많기 때문에 그분들이
무슨 고민을 하는지는 좀 많이 알게
됐거든요. 뭐 부동산 상담뿐만 아니라
뭐 상속 증여 상담이라든지 아니면
[음악] 이제 뭐 진짜 이민
상담이라든지 뭐 기타 뭐 등등
자산가분들이 되게 간지러워하고 되게
궁금해하던 그런 것들을 상담할 수
있는 [음악] 공간을 좀 만들려고
합니다. 그래서 아마 강남 지역에도
하나 있을 거고 그다음에 용상과
한남동 지점도 계획 중이긴 한데 아마
좀 장소만 괜찮고 거기를 운영하실 좀
센터장님을 괜찮은 분 찾으면 어
저희가 직접 이렇게 공간을 만들어서
이런 자산가들이 쉽게 상담할 수 있게
어 그런 장소를 만들려고 하고
있습니다. 그리고 해외 진출인데
저희가 최근에 두바이의 법인을 또
설립했어요. 그래서 중계 법인은
아니고 컨설팅 법인을 설립했습니다.
내년부터 좀 이렇게 본격적으로 해 볼
생각이에요. 한국 자산가들이 두바이
부동산을 투자한다라고 하면은 그런
것들을 저희가 뭐 좀 도와드릴 수
있을 것 같고 그리고 번 외적으로는
여행 상품을 만들려고 해요. 그러니까
두바이 부동산 투어 상품을 좀
만들려고 계획 중에 있습니다. 그래서
기존에 워낙 이제 뭐 얘기도 많이
듣고 그 뭐가 진실인지도 모르겠고
그리고 이제 어디를 봐야 되고 어떤
부동산을 사야 될지 모르시는 분들이
되게 많은데 저희가 그런 분들을
위해서 이렇게 단체로 정말 검증이
[음악] 된 분들만 좀 모셔 가지고
저희가 여행 상품을 만들려고 준비
중에 있습니다. 부동산 투어뿐만
아니라 비즈니스 투어도 [음악] 좀
계획 중이니까 이것도 좀 기대해
주시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고 내년 한
상반기 끝날 때쯤에는 저희가 두바이
세미나를 할 생각이에요. 그래서
괜찮은 강연장을 좀 구해 가지고 좀
이렇게 세미나도 개최할 예정이니까 어
많은 분들 좀 관심 가져 주셔도 좋을
것 같습니다. 그리고 내년에 또 숙제
중에 하난데 저희가 콘텐츠 개발에
신경은 굉장히 좀 많이 쓸
생각입니다. 그래서 제 내구적으로
콘텐츠 제작 팀도 있고 뭐 부동산뿐만
아니라 국어 콘텐츠도 많이 계획할
예정이고 그리고 더 나아가서는 두바이
부동산이라든지 이런 해외 부동산
콘텐츠들도 좀 많이 촬영할
예정이에요. 저희가 엔터테인먼트
회사도 있기 때문에 회사에 소속된
이런 중계사님들을 촬영해 주고 키워
주고 뭐 그런 것도 좀 계획 중에
있거든요. 아무튼 내년부터 좀이
콘텐츠 제작 콘텐츠 개발에 좀 노력을
많이 할 생각입니다. 그리고 요즘에
계속 키워드 중에 하나가 그
공간이에요. 그니까 워낙 그 공실이
높다 보니까이 공간을 어떻게 채워야
될지 뭐 그런 것들을 굉장히 좀
고민을 많이 하게 되거든요. 그래서
조금 위치가 떨어지는 곳들에 이런
공간들을 어떻게 채울지를 고민을 많이
하고 있습니다. 그런 공간을 채우는
사업을 할 생각이에요. 그래서 거기를
뭐 예를 들어서 독서실로 만들 수도
있고 아니면은 막 이제 공유 오피스로
만들 수도 있고 뭐 여러 가지 종류에
따라서 만들 수 있기 때문에 그런
공간을 어떻게 채우는지에 대해서
솔루션을 제시해서 나중에 저희가 뭐
중계한 것뿐만 아니라 기존에 있던
고객분들 저희가 평소에 연락하고 있던
그리고 이제 공실 때문에 되게
힘들었던 그런 분들을 어떻게 공시를
채워 줄 건지에 대한 그런 별도의
사업을 할 생각입니다. [음악]
그리고 이제 최근에 그 토큰 증권
발행 관련해 가지고 좀 이렇게
허가라든지 이런 법적 절차가 많이 좀
이렇게 진전이 됐어요. 그래서 뭐
내년 당장 하긴 좀 어렵긴 하겠지만
어찌 됐든 저도 부동산도 다 토큰화될
거라고 저는 예상을 하기 때문에 어
토큰 증권 시장에도 좀 이렇게 준비를
하면서 언젠가는 오늘 그날을 위해서
좀 준비를 할 생각이 있습니다. 네.
그래서 좀 정리를 해 보자면 우선
부동산 중개법인은 지금 빌딩 쪽에
비중이 좀 많이 싫어 있긴 하지만
주택 부분을 좀 많이 키울
생각입니다. 많은 분들이 주택을 안
하는 줄 알고 있는데 저희가 주택도
열심히 하고 잘한다는 거를 브랜딩을
좀 저희가 본격적으로 할 생각입니다.
그리고 두 번째로 건축이나 건설사도
운영 중인데 요즘에 뭐 경기가 안
좋다고 하긴 하지만 오히려 지금이
저는 더 기회라고 생각하거든요.
라디오 광고 혹시 들어 보신 분 계실
텐데 이럴 때일수록 더 광고하고 더
홍보하고 더 오랫동안 버텨 가지고
오히려 이런 시장에 더 독점적으로
잘할 수 [음악] 있게끔 어 내년에
좀 준비를 하려고 합니다. 그리고
패밀리 오피스 지점은 저희가 강남이랑
어찌 됐든 용산구에 하나 설립할
예정인데 어찌 됐든 괜찮은 공간이
나오거나 정말 [음악] 괜찮은
센터장님이 계신다면 저희가 모셔서
자산가분들이 편하게 와서 차안할 수
있는 공간을 만들려고 합니다. 네.
그리고 해외 진출은 저희가 두바이
법인을 11월 달에 설립을 했고
내년부터 좀 본격적으로 한번 해 볼
생각이에요. 그리고 이제 세미나도
열생각이고 투어 상품도 만들
예정이니까 여러분들 기대하셔도 좋을
것 같습니다. 그리고 콘텐츠 제작에는
제가 정말 진심이고 앞으로 더 열심히
해야 된다라고 생각이 들어서 콘텐츠
제작 팀을 더 키워서 국내 부동산뿐만
아니라 해외에 있는 그런 콘텐츠까지도
별도로 만들어서 진행할 예정이고요.
공간 사업 요즘에 뭐 워낙 공실이
많기 때문에 여기 공실을 어떻게 채울
건지 저희가 뭐 진짜 별도의 사업부를
만들어 가지고 그런 공간을 채울 수
있는 그런 사업을 할 수 있게끔
준비하는게 내년에 목표입니다. 그리고
마지막으로 STO가 당장 뭐 내년에
할 순 없겠지만 어찌됐든 모든 자산이
토크나 될 거라고 저는 생각을
합니다. 뭐 좀 준비를 지금부터 하면
어 나중에 뭐 진짜 3년 뒤, 5년
뒤 그 뭐 10년 뒤에 충분히 그
사업을 할 수 있다라고 생각하기
때문에 뭐 조금씩이라도 어 준비할
계획이니까 여러분들 좀 지켜봐 주시면
좋을 것 같습니다. 그리고 유튜브도
더 열심히 하겠습니다. 네. 더
열심히 하고 더 많이 촬영하고
여러분들한테 계속 좋은 정보 저희가
촬영해서 전달해 드리도록 하겠습니다.
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다.